The prospect of fatherhood was just...
...mind-boggling. I was terrified...
...because I wasn't ready.
I was not ready. I was 23 years old...
...and just blown away. I mean, I'm like, 'Wow, this child is going to be...'
I'm responsible for this kid.
If we want our children to succeed in life,...
...we need fathers to step up.
We need fathers to understand that their work doesn't end...
...with conception.
What truly makes a man a father is the ability to...
...raise a child.
Personally, I will hold myself somewhat responsible and accountable...
...for my child's actions when he grows to be an adult...
...or when she grows to be an adult.
So, I wanna make sure that they have all the tools and resources that they need...
...to grow into their own personalities and do what they want to do.
When my daughters were born,...
...I made a pledge to them and to myself that I would...
...do everything I could to give them some things I didn't have.
I decided that if I could be one thing in life,...
...it would be to be a good father.
You need to understand...
...what your child is going through,...
...how they're going through...
...whatever stage they are in their life.
And then reaching out to them,...
...getting on your hands and knees, getting at their level...
...and letting them see you eye to eye.
And it's just... try.
Try. Keep trying, keep learning. Human nature. You learn.
You keep learning throughout your whole life. So,...
...use it as an opportunity...
...and a challenge to learn more about each other.